foreign
[Music]
radio silent on me is that what this is
about just last night and I thought I
missed that [__] is that true
bonjourno that's my cousin Gary I swear
to God he's my cousin he's my second
cousin there's something seriously wrong
with you I'm an Uber driver and I don't
have a car I'm gonna lose my house you
think I chose this
[Music]
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shawl before College in exchange we'll
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
it's got to be a joke right no have you
seen these helicopter parents I'm
surprised they're not gonna [__] them
themselves
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it yeah we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter hi mind if I touch your
wiener what your dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house it's a
shortcut
you're my hostage
she got down there something for me
roll up this kid is unfuckable have a
drink together he'll have a Long Island
Iced Tea
[Music]
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
a thing about me I'm the baddest alive
dance party I don't know what to do I
just know my mom would have wanted me to
save the house he's probably just
nervous
why don't you loosen them up we can go
skinny dipping what about sharks
got the season it's really the lack of
life partner get the [__] in here right
now okay
I'm just a bit of a romantic he's
actually really sweet the best part
about getting older is not getting a
[__] what people think I'm an adult now
I can make my own decisions that's
that's good you want to save rent
[Music]
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get away from
her stay
I can't lose my license
okay
[Music]